الجمهور يختاروا عزله ماسك من اداره تويتر
المصريه فرح الدباني تخطف الانظار بنهائي
كاس العالم شبيه مبابي المصريه يخطف
الاضواء في قطر هذه الاخبار وغيرها انقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
الالماسك نتيجه استطلاع للراي عند ناحيه
من رئاسه منصه تويتر بمشاركه اكثر من 17
مليون شخص وبحسب ما اعلن مالك العصفور
الازرق صوت اكثر من 10 ملايين شخص بنعم
على قرار التنحيف بنسبه بلغت اكثر من 57%
فيما صوت اثنان واربعون بالمئه
مطالبينه بالبقاء وكان ماسك فجاه بس اطلعي
رايا لاخذهم حول تنحيه من منصبه كرئيس
تويتر مؤكدا الالتزامه بالنتيجه اين
هو في حفل ختام وديع القدر بين الارجنتين
وفرنسا خطفت المطربه المصريه فرح الديباني
انظار الملايين اثناء غناء النشيد الوطني
الفرنسي ماثر ظهورها تساؤلات عن هويتها
بين رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعيه وتعد
فرح اديباني ميزو سوبرانو مصريه عالميه
لفتت انظار العالم سابقا اثناء مشاركتها
في حفل تنصيب الرئيس الفرنسي
وهي اول مغنيه عربيه شابه
ما في مونديال ايضا خطف المصري شبيه
المهاجم كيليان مبابي الاجواء في العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه قبل ساعات من المباراه
النهائيه لمسابقه كاس العالم قطر 2022 بين
المنتخب بين الفرنسي والارجنتيني وتجمع
عشرات المشجعين حول الشاب المصري
لالتقاط الصور معه بعد ما قدم الى الدوحه
متمنيا فوزا المنتخب الفرنسي بالكاس هذه
ليست المره الاولى التي يظهر فيها شبيهه
احد نجوم كاس العالم حيث خطف شبيه نيمار
الاضواء في المدرجات بعد ان اعتقد 10 من
المشجعين بانه نجم المنتخب البرازيلي
نيمار فرعو للزقاقات الصور معه قبل اكتشاف
هويته الحقيقيه
بعت دميه دميه الاصليه للكائن الفضائي
الذي تمحورت حوله قصه فيلم اي تي مقابل
اثنين فاصل سته مليون دولار في مزاد عالمي
نظمته دار جوليانز الامريكي
وتمثل الدميه تحفه هندسيه صغيره تتالف من
مفصلا الميكانيكا يتيح تحريك الانف
والعينين والجفون والرقبه والذراعين فيما
يزال هذا الكائن الفضائي من اشهر شخصيات
الثقافيه والشعبيه واعمال الخال العلمي
منذ بدا عرض فيلم التي حقق نجاح ساحقا سنه